the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok welcome this grid it almost looks
like beginning of the fall at least
outside so what it's IEP so what we are
going to do is I think is going to be a
very exciting month and mainly the
reason for doing this course is I think
we are about a software crisis so
there's an interesting code I want to
start with this is somebody very famous
in computer science who spoke during his
Turing Award lecture
I mean his point was when the computers
were small there was no problem and
computers got bigger this pesky software
start having problems so the first
software crisis in fact happen around in
60s and 70s the problem for the first
software crisis was people are writing a
same language programs when the
computers are small and memory was small
it was completely doable no problem but
as computers became large and large it
became very hard to write assembly
language programs and what do you need
it is some kind of abstraction and
portability so you should be able to go
every two years do you know how to
rewrite the programs in there so you
need portability and you need some level
of abstraction so what that means is
instead of writing all assembly hacking
and dealing with every hardware feature
you can erase about that and the vba
sold it and that generation is we came
up with this high-level languages like
Fortran and C and what those did was
they kind of provided a common machine
language across these machines and so
what is this was they looked at all
these meshes those days the unit
processors and kind of abstracted out
first of all it takes all the common
properties is made it available for the
programmer so it didn't really let the
program go too far away from the machine
but it abstract it out all the
differences so you do it by doing that
we avoided we managed to get this
languages like C and Fortran was very
fast pretty efficient and working
through this thing so that's how we
avoided the first software crisis and I
think there's a lot of really good work
happen and then few people got Turing
awards for doing these kind of things
and then we faced the second software
crisis in 80s and 90s the problem here
was C was great if two guys sit in a
cone and write a program when Microsoft
start programming word word three with
about a few hundred programmers the
problem was the bugs never went away if
the project was supposed to finish in a
year it lasted three years and bulks
keep coming and coming and they had no
idea when the project was going to
finish because the way you write in a
small piece of code really didn't scale
and this was a huge crisis four people
said we will never be able to write
large programs because these programs
will never work they're going to be
brittle and the problem there is we want
to have able to software builds offer
that composable malleable and
maintainable so software should be
multiple people should be will do it
composite and when if requirement says
it should be easy to change and you
should maintain interesting thing is we
never cared about high performance at
that time more slow this nice low site
layout they start to take care of that
the way we solve that crisis again a lot
of people got very famous for doing that
is came up with things like
object-oriented programming languages C
shops
C++ and now she sharpened Java basically
made it possible for now hundreds if not
thousands of people to develop software
if you look at something like a new
Microsoft products coming out thousands
of people involved in and still they may
need to get it out on time and also we
did bunch of better tools things like
component libraries and tools like
purify and we develop lot of software
engineering methodology to develop
software we made it a more of a process
then kind of ad hoc art form this is
good so here we are today we are very
happy a lot of programmers here
unfortunally oblivious to what's
happening in hardware we don't care
programs that don't have to know about
what things are running we have this
nice virtual machines
and of course more slow this great new
thing is going to come and take care of
all of us and if you want speed just
wait for six months the machines will be
faster and that's the thing we have been
going on and nice thing is this programs
programs written in even in 70s still
run probably two three orders have been
queued fast because process today are
literally fast and this abstraction gave
us huge amount of power just say don't
care what's underneath we are going to
sit up there and just basically program
we were very happy with that the problem
is we are running into issue in here so
we are the beginning of this third
software crisis what I call the software
crisis due to the multi-core Menace so
multi kofo Hardware people is a lot good
opportunity but software people's kind
of a menace in their problem is
sequential programs are left behind by
Moore's law and as you see and probably
lot of you know that you are not going
to get performance on sequential
programs increased performance in there
we had deal with this and we need to
support the key thing here is so why
don't we just stop so you could we have
the programs we machines on today very
fast is that good enough the problem is
we won't evolve we need to support new
features we need to support things like
large datasets in the same program and
we kind of keep expecting a certain
performance gain every year to sustain
portability and malleability we assume
that every few years the progress the
machines performance will double because
we believe in that like for example
microphone at the beginning 10 years
we'd still work but it didn't have
spellcheck running back in the
background we didn't deal with very
large images we didn't deal with XML
kind of formats in there and then of
course next generation we probably won't
have to get video audio voice
recognition all those things in there
and we need that power we rely on that
power and and this is going to be a big
problem because see you can shell
program our stuff it's not going to
provide that power anymore
and it's critical this kind of power is
critical keep up the current rate of
evolution and if you get stuck there we
are going to have a big crisis happening
so how is this happening
so the I talked about Moore's law so
oh so this is like obligatory signed up
movers flow so if you look at it going
from even before 1970s we have this
amazing amazing growth in number of
transistors available so Moore's law
doesn't say anything but performance it
says about number of transistors
available on a die every 18 months is
double so this basically some people
even say this is the basis of this this
large to last two decades of economic
expansion because we got all this
amazing power because of this kind of
growth in here the problem is if you
look at performance it's flattening out
so this is spec numbers that are kind of
the value measure performance is have
the set of programs that we can keep
running on these machines and we keep
running on this same machines the even
though we are getting twice the amount
of transistors this is kind of
flattening out and then for last few
years it kind of almost constant we are
not getting anything in there and and so
we are still running from the fumes of
that amazing growth rates we had in this
time and we are kind of flattened out in
here and why is this and the main reason
for this is I will talk about four
things one is power consumption wire
delay and DRAM access time and
diminishing returns so I will go little
bit into these details to kind of give
you over why this happened the first
thing is power so as we go about we are
keep taking more and more power and
right now if you look at at the 1 volt
rate that normally with this one points
on wall that this processor run this
draws more current than any of your
houses back home ok I mean that's
amazing I mean how the houses probably
draw like 150 watts 150 amps and in one
wall it's 150 we are drawing 150 watts
so so this is like that much current
going to these things and then heat and
it's a big issue so this still shows ok
power is we are flattening out but
another interesting thing is power
efficiency so we are trying to use these
transistors we are trying to more and
more out of these transistors and if you
look at how much what you are spending
on what to get one of the spec race
that's base how much would to do the
same MO same on
work we are spending lot more power
because we are building these things
that are very marginal return today okay
that is the problem in building the
current superscalar type things because
it doesn't go this power efficiency this
is why Google is building their shops
next to the Grand Coulee Dam because
they are sucking in so much power
because the power efficiency a big issue
for them and today a microprocessor most
the cost of it is more than purchasing
it's basically the feeding it with power
and cooling it so another problem is
wire delay so we want to be if you try
to build this monolithic large process
so what happened is in the good old days
within a clock cycle in the processor
dies this side you can basically try a
friend over
send a wire for one end to another
processor still within one clock cycle
so if you are building this monolithic
thing it's almost like sitting in a room
when I talk the other end of the room
they will hear about it in in
instantaneously because the you are
talking slowly or the thing is
propagated you're clocking slowly here
and today we are around this area so
what that means is in a clock cycle you
can't get a wire for more than small
part of the chip so it's almost like
trying to communicate in in this
building so if I want to tell something
to everybody
I cannot broadcast I have to sell some
what he has to go to the next door tell
somebody to get the information through
the entire thing takes time and as he go
more and more this is going to be hard
and harder and harder and what that
means is trying to build large
monolithic processors like we did to
keep the more slow kind of performance
going it's not working and we have this
problem interesting third issue is a
dram access time so what's happening is
microprocessors are going like this
excess time it's getting performance
getting faster and faster DRAM gets
doubled only about every 10 years and
because of that there's this interesting
mismatch if you are trying to get to
DRAM if you put things in DRAM it's
almost about probably 10 years ago that
kind of like latency we had to the disk
is now we are having to be RAM so so the
way we look at this actually the cost of
it going to get big and it's also power
issue because if you are in on chip it's
much it's hundreds of two orders of
magnitude cheaper to get to a word on
chip then go all the way outside get to
the DRAM and get things out and so
between power and this this is also
creating huge amount of issue that
impossibility for us to keep this kind
of more slow type performance keep going
the final thing is diminishing returns
so if you look at 80s that is the year
of super scalars we had amazing
performance improvement so for example
when you start at the decade every CPI
spends a clocks per instruction how many
clocks you run to get one instruction
going at the beginning of the decade you
had to run about 10 clock cycles to
execute one instruction on the average
at the end of the decade we went about 1
clock cycles per instruction so every
clock cycle we get a new instruction
graduated from that and that give
amazing performance boost and then the
90s we had a a of diminishing returns we
kind of went from this 2-way superscalar
almost like six way out of Ford out of
issue branch prediction everything is
predicted and this huge pipeline
amazingly complex machines but we went
from one clock per instruction about
half a clock point instruction so we
just double that kind of performance and
performance a below expectations and
projects got delayed and canceled one
thing that saved I am NOT going to talk
about that much is at even this time you
could get the clock frequency going
higher and higher and because of power
and other physical limitation we are
also hitting a wall in clock frequencies
we are not getting there was at that
time if you realize everybody market is
saying how fast they are machine ran and
they have stopped that because they
can't get machines double their
frequencies again more so between those
two your performance kind of stuck
so that is why and now we are starting
in the new era of multi course we need
explicit parallels we can't build this
large monolithic things that keep giving
you performance every few years that
stop and we can build a
sequential machine what you get in ten
years time will almost be the same as
what we get today but we get more and
more silicon it's doubling the most or
still keep going so what do you do with
that silicon is kind of replicate and
build more and that's where we are going
into and so if you look at what's
happening
the únicos are all a dying breed
the last big one was Intel had this
projects that try to build very fast
amazing superscalar machines all those
project has to get cancelled because
they could not get the performance the
power was way too high they could not
get the power in there and those things
got canceled and as you see there's more
and more multi-course are coming in
there so in fact if you look at multi
Kosar there here is in a big way so if
you look at all these machines they only
put the pentium line of unit process and
then from recent times they had been for
post eight course and even machines that
have more than 256 cores small cause but
but we are basically going in that's a
new trend and if you look at the trend
line it's interesting trend line going
in there so what I'm going to do now is
switch gears because the PC of I'm in
the right slide yeah switch gears
because we have Mike Brown from IBM we
are very fortunate to have him here to
give us a feel about the Cell processor
because we are going to spend this month
really getting to understand cell pros
and really taking advantage of that and
he had done huge amount of work itself
he's at IBM TJ Watson and so he's going
to get an X probably hour hour and a
half he is going to give us a lowdown on
cell and then I will conclude with a
little bit more remarks about how we are
going to do the class the class
structure and that will carry to the end
of the day ok Mike hopefully he had to
catch a flight so we will kind of go
fast hopefully you guys in at least in
the first lecture go without too much of
a break so if things get too tired let
us know so we will see if they can put a
break in the middle